Welcome to "Ear Biscuits".
The podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the Round
Table of Dim Lighting
we are revisiting some lyrics to songs
that we did not understand as kids
but now that we are menfolk
and fully understand.
Experienced.
All the things that there
are to understand in life,
well we are just slightly more
than we understood at the time.
Wow.
Kind of blown away with
what we were singing
and what we were rapping and
what we were talking about
back in the day.
And I wanna contrast it to
how things are these days.
So, but go ahead and tell me,
how did you get into this?
This was a Shepherd conversation?
Yeah so last week on the same evening,
my boys had, Shepherd had
his middle school dance
and Locke had his high school prom.
So boy was just you know,
lots of pictures being
taken, et cetera, et cetera.
And I think that there's.
You feeling the dance fever?
I think that there is, as
I think we said last time.
There will be a, your approach to prom
slash middle school dances
because next year you know,
Lincoln'll still be, he'll have the prom.
Shepherd'll have another
middle school dance.
So it'll still be fresh.
Yeah.
So we can kind of give
the dads giving advice to, to kids episode
during the season.
When it's more pertinent.
But this is how this came up
because I was just talking
to Shepherd and I was like,
"So you gonna, you think you
gonna get out there and dance?"
I don't know how these
things work anymore.
Your generation's so weird.
Yeah.
And they've all been
cooped up in this pandemic.
They don't know how to
speak to each other.
They forgot what the bottom
half of faces look like.
There's just a lot to
overcome and he said,
"I don't know you know?"
I was like, "You gonna
ask a girl to dance?"
And he's like, "I don't know."
There's lots of I don't knows.
Oh.
Which is I guess,
a good place to be.
I wouldn't think so.
But then he started
asking me.
He was like, "Well tell me about
your middle school dances."
And that led to talking
about the time that we did,
which we wrote about in
the "Book of Mythicality"
where we basically did a lip sync contest.
Where you were.
Oh yeah.
You were, which is so appropriate
now that you're becoming a
DJ in your second career.
You lip synced as a DJ.
I would pantomime.
Yeah.
As DJ Jazzy Jeff, yeah.
Anyway, and then that led to.
As it turns out, I still have no clue
how he does what he does now.
That led to a conversation about us using
every opportunity we got to perform
for our fellow students.
Yeah.
Which led to the conversation about
taking over the fall
festival in seventh grade?
Eighth grade?
I think it
was seventh grade.
I mean it could've been sixth grade.
And turning that opportunity,
of being able to, just
having everyone assembled
at the fall festival which was
a way to talk about Halloween
without saying Halloween I
guess in a small, Christian,
conservative community.
Yeah.
And how we took the song "O.P.P."
by Naughty by Nature and made it,
instead of, "You down with OPP."
"You down with Halloween."
Which we had the privilege.
Yeah.
Of performing live
on "The Tonight Show"
backed up by The Roots.
Can you believe that happened?
Damn.
Like in the stories
we'll tell on the porch.
I do think that it's
a, it's a career peak.
Yeah I mean it's not gonna.
Hopefully there's
more peaks.
It's not gonna get
any better than that.
We may get back there.
We've had.
We've had a number of high points
but that's definitely one of them.
And so that led to me saying,
"You know what?"
It was the first rap we
ever wrote and performed.
It wasn't something,
I'm still baffled by the
fact that it happened
because it wasn't like every
year at the fall festival
some students would get up and perform.
Like at the talent,
I mean at the dances yeah
it was a lip sync contest.
You would enter.
Yeah.
I approached the administration
and asked permission to do this.
Yeah, it's just something that you took
the initiative to do.
It was with no, you know.
The pattern had not been set.
You have to set the pattern.
It's crazy.
But that led to me saying,
"Have you ever heard 'O.P.P.'?"
To Shepherd.
And of course he hadn't.
And while Shepherd is
a connoisseur of music
and listens to a lot of old school stuff,
he doesn't listen to
much old school hip hop.
So.
Yeah.
I turned on "O.P.P." and
began to play it and I,
of course I know what it's about.
I know what OPP stands for.
Because that's what the
song is telling you about
the whole time. But I was.
Well it was
other people's property.
But as you'll get into the lyrics
it's more specific than that.
It's very specific.
So you played
the song for Shepherd.
And he was just like,
like putting his hand on his forehead
and like just shaking his head.
But was he listening to
the lyrics or was he,
was he reacting to the
production or just the style?
So we listened to the first verse
and he was taking in a
lot right and then I said,
"Shepherd, are you really
listening to the lyrics?"
Uh-huh.
And he said, "Kinda."
And I said, "Okay, well
we're starting over."
So I rewound it,
well I didn't rewind, that
doesn't happen anymore.
I'm old, I just started the song again
and at that point it was
when he was processing
exactly what was being said
which you know we don't have,
there's no embarrassment in our family
about talking about these things.
So it wasn't like, "Oh dad,
"I can't believe you're doing
this, you're embarrassing me."
He was just like, "I can't
believe that this was a thing
"that was happening culturally I guess."
But it's still, it's still happening
as we might demonstrate later but, I.
It was a huge song.
I mean it was everywhere.
It was definitely a crossover hit.
It was like middle school dances
absolutely planned the song.
And like I said I knew what it was about
but I just had forgotten
the explicit nature.
So I'm going to read
the lyrics to "O.P.P.".
And this came out August 24th 1991.
So we were 13.
And for effect just to clarify,
I will not be trying to
deliver these rhythmically
or in any relation to the song.
Not for legal purposes
but because it is more entertaining
to read them as if you are reading a poem.
"Arm me with harmony.
"Dave, drop a load on 'em."
Yeah.
Those are some introductory
things that were said.
Yeah and I guess Dave was the DJ or.
He was.
And he was dropping
the beat.
Yeah.
"OPP, how can I explain it?
"I'll take it, frame by frame it.
"To have y'all."
"Jumpin' shall we singin' it."
I don't know, that's what the.
Only one rule, you can't
start doing the lyrics
and singing the song.
That's my only rule.
I'm not gonna sing it.
Let me go through these.
Okay, okay.
You go through yours.
"To have y'all all jumpin',
shoutin', singin' it.
"O is for Other, P is for
People, scratch your temple."
Yeah, think about it.
Think about it.
The last.
"The last P, well,
that's not that simple."
Huh?
"It's sorta like, oh well,
"another way to call a cat a kitten."
Yeah.
"It's five little letters
that are missin' here
"You get it on occasion if
the other party isn't gaming.
"It seems I gotta start the explaining.
"Bust it."
Yep.
"You ever had a girl and
met her on a nice hello?"
Hello.
"You get her name and number,
"then left feeling real mellow.
"You get home, wait a day,
she's what you wanna know about.
"Then you call up and
it's her girlfriend's
"or her cousin's house."
Oh.
"It's not a front,
"an F to the R to the
O to the N to the T."
Yep, that is how you spell it.
"It's just her boyfriend's at her house.
"Oh, that's why she's scary."
Ah.
"It's OPP time, other
people's, but you get it.
"There's no room for relationships,
"there's just room to hit it."
Hit it.
"How many brothers out there
"know just what I'm gettin' at?
"You think it's wrong
'cause I was splittin'
"and co-hittin' that."
Co-hittin' that, that's a good lyric.
"Well if you do, that's OPP
and you're not down with it.
"But if you don't,
here's your membership."
Oh.
"You down with OPP?"
You can do this part.
"Yeah you know me."
"You down with OPP?"
I don't feel comfortable saying
yeah you know me actually.
"Who's down with OPP?"
"All the homies."
Every last homie.
"You down with OPP?"
"Yeah you know me."
"Who's down with OPP?"
All the homies.
Well.
And now we gotta
flip the script.
"For the ladies, OPP
means something gifted.
"The first two letters the same
"but the last is something different."
You see how he got to different?
Yeah.
Probably tried different
the first time.
Now don't be.
No commentary on the lyrical choices.
I don't want to criticize.
This is a classic, it's a hit.
Treach has a lot of respect.
Better than I could've done.
As is.
As a lyricist.
As is evidenced by, "You
Down With Halloween"
which we will not be reading.
"It's the longest, loveliest,
lean, I call it the leanest."
He's gotta get to that rhyme.
"It's another five letter word rhymin'
"with cleanest or meanest."
So he's talking about penist.
The past tense of being penised.
You have been penised, man.
Oh my gosh.
"I won't get into that," really?
"I'll do it, ah, sorta properly.
Yeah.
I say the last P,
"hmmm stands for property."
Property.
"Now lady here comes a kiss,
blow a kiss back to me.
"Now tell me, exactly,
"have you ever known a
brother who had another,
"like ah girl or a wife?
"And you just had to stop a toast,
"'cause he looked just that nice?"
Now first of all, some
of these lyric sites,
this is genius.com.
Sometimes they get it wrong.
So don't hold that against us.
It sounds right-ish to me.
"You looked at him, he looked at you
"and you knew right away,
"he had someone but he
was gonna be yours anyway.
"You couldn't be seen with him at all
"and still you didn't care
"'cause in a room behind a door
no one but y'all are there.
"When y'all are finished, y'all can leave
"and only y'all would know.
"And y'all could throw that skeleton bone
"right in the closet door."
Do'.
"Now don't be shy 'cause if you're down
"I want your hands up high.
"Say OPP.
"I like to say it with pride.
"Now when you do it, do it
well and make sure it counts.
"You're down with a discount."
Look can I just interject and say
you have never sounded more white dad.
Yeah, right.
Than you do right now.
Well, I'm a white dad.
Just being myself.
And the same thing happens again.
The whitest and daddest.
This time it's, "Every last
lady and all the ladies."
I won't make you
go through that.
Yeah, it goes both ways.
It takes two to tango.
And let me just.
Well, it actually takes
at least three but only two are tangoing.
This is a long song,
let me just rush through the third verse.
I don't even remember
the third verse.
"A scab tried to OPP me.
"I had a girl and she knew that.
"Matter of fact, her and
my girl was partners that.
"Had a fallout, disagreement, yeah."
They were friends.
"An argument.
"She tried to do me so we
did it in my apartment.
"Bust it.
"That wasn't the thing,
"it must've been the way
she hit the ceiling."
Whoa.
Okay.
"'Cause after that she kept on coming back
"and catching feelings.
"I said, 'Let's go, my girl is coming.
"'So you gotta leave.'
"She said, 'Oh no, I love you Treach.'"
Treach.
Treach?
Yeah.
He spelled it with an E-A.
"I said,
"'Now child please, you gots to leave.
"'Come grab your coat right now.
"'You gotta go.'
"I said, 'Now look you chose the stairs
"'or choose the stair window.'"
Oh my gosh.
"That was a fling, a little thing,
"you shouldn't have brought your heart.
"'Cause you know I was OPP.
"Hell, from the very start.
"Come on, come on.
"Now let tell you what it's all about.
"When you get down you can't
go running off at the mouth.
"That's rule number one
in this OPP establishment.
"You keep your mouth shut
and it won't get back
"to her or him."
Exciting isn't it?
"A special kind of business.
"Many of you will catch
the same sort of OPP.
"Messing with him or her for sure.
"I'm going to admit it,
"when OPP comes, damn
skippy, I'm with it."
The thing that strikes
me is.
So I let my 13-year-old
be educated by that.
We never received this level of education.
We never thought about
the lyrics in this way.
I mean there were
certain songs at the time
that I was thinking about the lyrics.
If it was a story song or
if it was something really,
just blatant like Young MC
rapping about "Bust a Move".
You got this girl at the wedding
and you're feeling like
you want to be with somebody.
That was the only way
I could follow it.
This.
It washed over you.
This isn't hard to
follow but rhythmically,
it was so catchy and it was
a little harder to follow
because he was and is a really good MC.
So I'm gonna put it on
that and not just on us.
But, I mean and this was.
But we were kids as well.
It was such a huge song
but we were listening to other
lyrics and processing them
but I never thought this is
something that I disagree with.
Cheating, like glamorizing,
glorifying cheating on your
partner as something that,
that is set up as a cultural norm.
Hey if everybody's playing
by these same rules,
there's nothing wrong
here if nobody finds out.
You know it's like?
I would've felt, I mean we
wouldn't agreed with that
but we were also middle schoolers.
But we also.
If we would've
thought about it.
But that's not how we.
It wouldn't have given
us license.
I don't think anyone thinks
about music in that way.
Well parents do.
Adults do, adults do.
Parents are like,
"Oh you can't listen to this."
Because you will adopt the philosophy
of the person rapping who may or may not
be playing a character by the way.
Do you know what I'm saying like?
Yeah, definitely.
But that was never a danger.
I never thought about
having sexual license
as a middle schooler.
Now if I was in college listening to this,
it might give me some oomph.
Of course not in, not when
we were in the college.
The way we were in college,
we were listening to this
stuff and I will note,
you know I'm talking about college.
But to go back to this exact era.
Taking the N. W. A. tapes
that your brother would secretly buy
and sometimes they would be so raunchy
that he would find a way
to edit the tapes himself.
Like censor the tapes.
A couple of songs he had
to censor the entire song
off the tape.
I think "Just Don't Bite
It" was one of them.
Yeah, so and we were
listening to that stuff too.
It was like musical pornography.
Oh it was so explicit.
And very misogynistic.
We didn't listen to
2 Live Crew.
It was very problematic.
But yeah we heard it.
You're right.
But for some reason we drew
the line at 2 Live Crew.
Well my brother did.
Well, I don't,
I don't think your
brother liked the music.
It wasn't as good.
It wasn't.
Miami.
It wasn't nearly.
The Miami sound is not
something that we really liked.
It wasn't as good as N. W. A..
It just kind of, and that
was at the exact same time.
So those lyrics were
blatantly pornographic.
I mean they were like,
they were sound effects
of sex acts.
And skits.
And so all of this stuff was happening.
So this was, this was coded.
It wasn't that coded.
This is where I could be popular.
But it wasn't.
Like on radio.
But there were no curse words.
And so it played on the radio.
Yeah there was not profanity.
N. W. A. wasn't playing on the radio.
Oh yeah.
Well one of the things
that I think that there's a,
it's interesting because
you would listen to raps.
It reached number six on the Hot 100.
You would listen to raps.
A pop hit.
To learn lyrics.
I never did that.
That was not, I would never,
I'm gonna listen to this again
so I can learn the lyrics.
I might learn them by osmosis.
Yeah.
Just listening over time.
But I just, I didn't ever.
It didn't, I didn't start
processing lyrics to songs
until I was an adult and I still often
don't process lyrics to songs.
Unless it's like,
"Oh this is really.
"This is something meaningful here
"and I'm gonna really listen to it."
So I'd say 95% of the music
that I listened to as a kid
was just washing over me and not.
Yeah, yeah.
And I couldn't have told you
what it was about.
Yeah.
And I think
that's relatively common.
All it takes
is a little coding.
That's what he did.
Just a little bit.
It's the longest, lean.
Some call it the leanest.
There's another five letter word
rhyming with cleanest and meanest.
That's not a lot of coding.
No not really but we
didn't think about it.
He's talking about penis, what, what?
So you're saying that you didn't know
he was talking about
penis when he said that?
If I knew he was talking about
penis I didn't like then,
I didn't then zoom out to try
to interpret the whole song.
It's like in that line
he says something about wieners.
It just sounds, I had this tape.
I listened to every song on this tape.
So imma skip to another,
I'm gonna go to 1995.
But first, hey we gotta
talk about MythiCon
on this freaking podcast.
Yeah tickets are available
to everyone, not just
Mythical Society members.
So listen, MythiCon,
the most Mythical event
in the history of Mythicality.
The most Mythicality put into one weeked
in Austin, Texas.
This is a convention
in real life.
Do we need to say that?
Yeah, it's MythiCon.
It's a convention.
Mythical Beasts.
Austin, Texas.
Descending upon a like,
Western town outside of Austin, Texas
that we're basically going
to just take over this town
for a couple of days and.
It's like a Mythical circus
coming through a Western town.
It has this sideshow.
It's not, I was gonna say Ren Faire.
But no it is not Ren Faire.
But in the way that
like, we're going all in.
You're entering another
world, in that way it is.
October 28th through the 30th,
get your tickets now before they are gone.
It's going to be worth it.
This is gonna be history-making.
It's gonna be something
that we can build on.
You know and say.
Yep.
Hey this is an amazing experience
for the select group of people.
It's limited capacity you know?
With this venue that we've got.
Centrally located, that's
why we picked Austin
and also because the venue
is thematically awesome.
That limited the number
of tickets we could sell
to create an experience for the people
who were able to get a ticket.
Yeah.
So I'm concerned it's
gonna sell out quickly.
We'll see how it goes but
don't take that chance.
This is where you want to be.
With us in Austin for that weekend.
So it's MythiConTickets.com
to get those tickets.
There's different packages
that you can get as well.
And I will say that you know,
we've been talking about
this and planning this
for multiple years.
Honestly, since we stopped touring.
Yeah.
And just,
with our schedules and the way
that things are sort of
structured with all the stuff
that we have to do.
The thinking was,
"Hey instead of traveling around,
"let's have everyone come to one place."
Right?
Yep.
And so,
this is what we're putting.
This is what we're investing in.
This is what we're trying
to put the most Mythicality
all together in person
in a way that we've never done before.
So we really hope to see you
for the most Mythical experience possible.
MythiCon 2022.
So MythiConTickets.com.
I'm gonna go to 1995 like I said.
I gotta talk about how Alanis Morissette
came on the scene.
Yeah.
She brought it.
You know,
you oughta know, there's
a great documentary.
I can't remember what it's
called now but it's on HBO.
All about her rise to fame.
It's really good, especially
the first two thirds.
But you oughta know, I mean she's upset.
She's, her man, who some
people say is Dave Coulier
but she's not coming out and saying that.
She says it's like an
amalgamation of people
in the documentary.
She skirts the issue.
It's not the type of thing that like,
she seemed to say it was kind
of a ridiculous assumption.
But she didn't.
And that's.
She didn't address it directly.
Which uncle is that from "Full House"?
Uncle Danny?
He's the one with the.
I know he's the wild one.
The comedian.
Yeah but what's his name?
Joey, Uncle Joe.
Uncle Joe.
Joey, okay I'm right.
I want you to know I'm happy for you.
I mean at her age, she was so
young writing these lyrics.
"I wish nothing but the best for you both.
"An older version of me,
is she perverted like me?"
This is the very beginning of the song.
"Would she go down on you in a theater?"
What does that mean?
Right there.
One, two, three, four,
five lines into the song.
I think it means she goes
to pick up your popcorn
if you drop it.
Yeah.
Just making,
thinking about the theater staff.
"Does she speak eloquently
and would she have your baby?
"I'm sure she'd make a
really excellent mother."
Yeah, would.
"Would she go down on you in a theater?"
I mean the second verse really,
I never thought about that.
I didn't know what that meant.
Going down in a theater?
Yeah.
I don't think I knew
at the time.
What year are you saying, 95?
I mean.
Not, oh yeah I knew that.
I think we knew,
well I guess we knew by that point.
Yeah.
But you didn't think.
But somebody had to tell us.
You don't wanna think it
was on the radio though?
It's like there's no way
that's what she means
if this is on the radio.
The second.
Somebody from Dunn
had to tell us.
Second verse hits hard too.
"You've seen very well,
things look peaceful.
"I'm not quite as well."
Yeah we kind of picked up on that.
"I thought you should know.
"Did you forget about me Mr. Duplicity?
"I hate to bug you in
the middle of dinner."
So you realize, this entire exchange
is a confrontation where he's
out on a date with her.
He's on a date.
Saying these things.
She's there.
Yeah.
Does she go down
on you in a theater?
I don't know.
Does she speak eloquently?
Maybe later.
Is she gonna have,
oh I'm sure she'd make
an excellent mother.
Like she's there.
We're going to see
"Titanic" later.
It's pretty great.
"It was a slap in the face,
how quickly I was replaced
"and are you thinking of me when you her?"
Oh Link.
So that got,
that was bleeped on the radio.
Yeah.
But I mean,
that was quite an entrance to the scene.
So I, it was hard to ignore.
I think the down on you in a theater.
Yeah we had to know what
that meant at the time
and boy that was, it was just,
it was intriguing.
I think by 95.
You've got this
whole grunge thing.
Is starting to happen.
Well by 95
The two of us.
You've got this chick
who's bringing it.
The two of us are well
established in a Christian band.
Making our own music at the time.
Listening to secular music exclusively.
Secular, secular, secular.
The only time,
learn about them nuclear bombs.
The, I don't remember thinking,
I didn't buy an Alanis
Morissette tape or CD.
But I was like, oh that's catchy.
It's a catchy song.
But she felt dangerous,
a little bit dangerous.
Even though we listened to secular music,
it felt like we would divide
things into sort of you know,
Godly and worldly right?
And she was definitely on the worldly side
and she was kind of reveling
in it just a little bit.
She was a little scary,
a little intimidating.
At the time.
Yeah it,
that's unabashed subversion which was.
I mean, but she was really
just telling us something
that was true to her experience.
That tapped into what you know,
just the rage of like being dumped.
But I think what I'm saying
is that we had a tendency to lose.
Because with our worldview,
you just put two things in two categories.
Like this is good and this
is bad and worldly right?
Yeah.
And when you do that,
you have a filter, it kind
of just shifts everything
into the worldly box.
All the nuance and all the wisdom
and all the interesting
insights that you can get
from that art.
Yeah.
Is lost.
So you're just like this is not.
Again, we weren't prudes.
So we didn't, we listened to it
but we secretly judged it
as we were listening to it
and we never thought
that like this is like,
this isn't just a catchy song.
But you know, this is
about a woman scorned.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
And eloquently bringing,
I mean it's still very 90s
lyrics in a lot of ways.
But you know, you just lose
all the nuance of everything.
Yeah.
Because I remember thinking,
I was so into A Tribe Called Quest,
I'm actually wearing a shirt today.
Because.
I'm actually wearing
a shirt today.
Instead of being.
It says it.
Instead of being shirtless
like I was planning on.
That's what it sounded like
you were saying.
Yeah in 91,
when I really got into them.
There was this, I was relieved
that they rarely cursed
and it was pretty tame.
It was a choice that they made.
So I didn't feel.
They were very cool.
One of the best, it was
a classic hip hop album
but it was like,
I had permission to listen
to it without feeling like
I had to sneak around or like
I was doing something wrong.
Yep, right.
It was, it was the first tape
that I had that was like,
it felt safe to me.
But still very cool.
Mm-hmm, yeah.
For that reason.
What you got next?
'Cause I got some stuff.
I mean I had to hit
the Alanis theater line
but we may have some overlap here
'cause there's some stuff
in those middle school,
early high school days
that is just ridiculous
on the radio.
I'm gonna talk about Garth Brooks.
Oh you are?
That Summer.
Okay you're gonna go in this direction.
Okay, yeah yeah yeah, yeah.
I love it, this is such a good song.
Now.
This was a story song.
Garth Brooks, it's funny because,
well I think one reason
is because he doesn't
put his music on Spotify.
But I also,
I was so into Garth
Brooks in middle school.
Yeah you were.
And a little bit of,
a little bit in high school.
But.
It was justified.
But I didn't remain a Garth Brooks fan.
I didn't listen to Garth
Brooks in college really.
I didn't listen to Garth Brooks in,
I didn't do it in my 20s, 30s.
Yeah.
You know,
you can go back and
listen to it and I'm like,
"It's interesting how
this music broke through
"in such a big way and
it connected with me
"in such a significant way."
But I listen to it now and I'm like,
"It wasn't as good as I remember it."
I don't know what it is.
Well if it's not on Spotify.
You listen to it on Apple or something?
How are you even getting it?
You going to Walmart where
it's exclusively sold
or something?
No it's through,
I know.
There's a way that you can listen to it.
I can't remember how I have.
And it didn't.
Maybe Amazon.
I don't know.
It didn't tap into it
for you.
No but this song.
That's surprising.
This song, "That Summer".
What I would do is I would sit
in the back seat of the car
when my family was driving
and going someplace and we
would put on Garth Brooks
and I would sing it and they would like,
"Rhett sing that song.
"Sing the river."
♪ No dream is like a river ♪
I mean for those first two albums,
I don't think he missed.
Every song was just great.
But I'm pretty sure my
parents never got me
to sing this song in their presence.
"I went to work for her that summer.
"A teenage kid so far from home.
"She was a lonely widow woman,
"hell bent to make it on her own.
"We were a thousand miles from nowhere.
"Wheat fields as far as I could see.
"Both needing something from each other,
"not knowing yet what that might be."
Well I think one party might have known
what that might be.
"'Til she came to me one evening."
Oh.
"Hot cup of coffee
"and a smile."
Ooh, a coffee in the evening.
This is, what's the late night?
"In a dress that I was certain
"she hadn't worn in quite a while.
"There was a difference in her laughter,
"there was a softness in her eyes."
Yeah.
"And on the air
"there was a hunger even
a boy could recognize."
A boy, okay so a boy here.
He's a teenager.
A teenage kid and she's
a lonely widow woman.
So.
I mean in my mind
he's again, listen.
Let's say,
can we say he's 18?
We really can't.
I mean.
Let's just say that
for the benefit of everyone.
He's 18.
She's 46.
Yeah she is.
But actually she may be.
I don't know, well no she's a farm woman.
We get some details about
her physically in a second.
Okay.
But she's been in the sun
so it's kind of hard to tell if.
Well let's get to it.
But we're assuming they're
both in their sexual prime
at this point which is.
Well sexual prime for a
woman is what, early 30s?
Okay.
So I think she's
beyond that.
Well let's see.
But she's still feeling the thunder.
Because oh yeah.
She had a need to feel the thunder.
This is the chorus.
"To chase the lighting from the sky.
"To watch a storm with all its wonder,
"raging in her lover's eyes."
Wow.
"She had to ride."
Yes.
"The heat of passion
"like a comet burning bright.
"Rushing headlong in the wind,
"out where only dreams have been.
"Burning both ends of the night."
That is a good chorus.
Burning both ends of the night.
I mean that is,
I mean burning both ends of the night.
That means you're staying
up until the morning man.
Yeah, I mean that means you're making love
at both ends of the night.
Hold on, what?
This is about making love?
I don't know, maybe.
Second verse.
"That summer wind was all around me."
Oh, okay.
So they're outside.
"Nothing between us but the night."
Yep.
"And when I told her
"that I'd never."
So they're naked.
"She softly whispered,
"'That's all right.'
"And then I watched her hands of leather."
Okay, she's 80.
"Turn to velvet in a touch."
Well hands of leather?
Okay, you know 80 is like age spots.
That's.
I have some age spots.
No no okay again, I'm placing this woman.
She's a farm woman.
She's worked the land.
She's been in the sun.
Well she may not have
worked the land necessarily
but she's working for herself now.
She's a widowed woman that lives out
on the plains.
That she's working on.
She's working the week.
And this time,
he's singing this song in the 90s.
And of course it didn't happen to him
but if it had happened to him,
it would've happened in like the 80s, 70s.
Sunscreen not really a thing.
I think you can have
leathery skin at 40 honestly.
Okay, let's say she's 40.
But lonely widow woman.
Well he, you know.
We're pushing late 40s.
No I think you know,
he got some sort of I don't know.
A young man's disease, what's that?
Benjamin Button?
No I mean, he died young.
You know car accident, tractor
accident, I don't know.
Oh the husband.
Yeah.
She's 40.
She's 46.
Let's say she's 43.
I think you gotta push it upper 40s man.
Hands of leather, he's
really selling it here.
Fine.
"Then I watched her hands of leather
"turn to velvet."
"To velvet in a touch.
"There's never been another summer
"when I have ever learned so much."
So he just leaves the verse there.
Wow.
She had a need to feel
the thunder.
Wow.
He goes back into the chorus, chasing
lightning from the skies.
Wow, wow, wow.
Watch the storm and all that's
raging in her lover's eyes.
Well she taught him things.
You know?
Right, the heat of passion.
Things that she had learned on the farm.
Rushing what?
Headlong.
Rushing headlong.
You know what the head is.
Long.
Mm-hmm, in the wind.
Now where only dreams have been.
He's fantasized.
Someone's fantasized, it
might be her about this.
Now this is, let me just say okay.
I'm gonna be a little vulnerable here
and I appreciate not being
immediately judged for it
but I'm sure I will be.
But I just gotta say that for most,
when we were in high school,
most boys, without exception,
had a fantasy to get with a teacher.
Okay, I'm just gonna say.
It was highly inappropriate.
I'm not saying it's.
You don't even have
to say most boys.
But yeah it was a trope.
It was a common, it was common.
I am staking my claim on most boys
had a fantasy about being with a teacher.
If there was what they
would consider a hot teacher
at the school okay?
Seemed like a great idea to me.
There you go.
We're two boys, our sample size is two.
And we both thought it would be awesome.
Yeah.
And so,
and I'm not commenting on the morality
of any of that.
I'm just saying that
this is something that,
this is a fantasy that lives in the minds
and the loins of many teenage boys.
And I think that Garth understood
that in a powerful way.
And so I think that's why
the song was so popular
but nobody wanted to talk about it.
Nobody wanted to admit
that's why it was popular.
Give me the third verse
because I want to see if we can remember
how much we processed.
Okay.
But you can't leave out the third verse.
"I often think about that summer."
Okay, so now he's looking back on it.
How does he feel about it now?
"The sweat, the moonlight and the lace."
Okay.
"And I have rarely held another
"when I haven't seen her face."
Oh wow.
Her wrinkly, leathery face.
"And every time I pass a wheat field,
"and watch it dancin' with the wind.
"Although I know it isn't real
I just can't help but feel
"her hungry arms again."
Wow, so there's a bit of.
It defined sexuality for
him in a lot of ways.
You know it's like this kind of,
he's been saddled with it.
He's been saddled with
that experience and.
But he's taking the
lessons that she taught him
into every subsequent relationship.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, but he's like still seeing her.
She was his.
He's like obsessed with her.
She was his sensei.
She's dead now you know?
She aged out.
Oh that's hard living
out there in the wind.
Right, it's like.
Blow you right into
the grave.
Was it only older women from there on out?
I don't know.
Older women make beautiful lovers.
That is another song.
Yeah,
not gonna read those lyrics.
Do you remember like,
just really, really
jiving with these lyrics.
I don't.
Okay, I'm gonna be,
another step of vulnerability.
Oh here we go.
I'm gonna say that I am 90% sure.
Try to tell me like you
would if you were Treach.
You know you gotta veil it a little bit.
No, no.
Well no I'm speaking mathematically.
I am 90% sure that 30% of the time
that I listened to this
song I had an erection.
Oh, 90% sure that 30%.
And I do, 90% sure
that 30% of the time.
Of the time.
So what's 90%?
Almost positive
that a third of the time
that I listened to this song
that I got an erection.
Well you're really saying you could,
like almost like you're
saying 23% of the time
with 100% certainty.
I don't, you had an erection.
That's still almost a quarter of the time.
Means I probably had an erection.
Yeah.
So yes, to your.
In the backseat
of the car with your parents.
I said that they didn't,
they knew what was up.
They didn't ask me to sing this one.
Yeah but just, it comes on the radio.
Yeah, no I'm talking
about alone in my room.
Passionately singing this
and then just trying not to masturbate.
So I want to go.
Just to be honest with you.
I have something that's
almost directly related
but role reversal.
So I want to go there next,
but before I do I just want
to acknowledge that like,
nowadays, the stuff that you can get on,
like I was, I was like,
I'm gonna pick a
different Spotify playlist
besides Rap Caviar to listen to
while I'm coming down this mountain.
I was like, "I'm gonna
put on 'Feeling Myself'".
This is another playlist.
The Hip Hop Playlist that's a whole mood.
I was like, "Well I need a
mood going down this mountain."
Well it turns out it's
basically all female rappers.
You've got like Megan Thee Stallion,
Nicki Minaj, Doja Cat,
Erica Banks, Coi Leray.
But.
Okay.
I mean, so I mean,
especially by the time WAP comes along.
I mean it's like, yeah.
You with some wet ass.
Okay, pretty explicit.
Yeah.
This is again and again
and again.
Until like just referring to you know,
it's a female empowerment song.
It's like hey, I like sex.
I have sex organs.
I have desires.
And I can be in charge
and I can say how I want this done
and I can say what I bring to the table
and I cannot apologize for anything.
So there's this whole movement
that you know, you've got.
"I'm just trying to slut this N-word out.
"Slut him out.
"Gargle on his kids, then
spit 'em in his mouth."
Oh my goodness.
"I told him slurp me up like spaghetti.
"He thought he was a freak til he met me."
Oh gosh.
"And now I'm finna show him
"what it's 'bout."
Gargle on his kids?
Yeah so this is Baby Tate.
"Slut Him Out Again".
You know there's a, correct
me if I'm wrong here.
Jen is the expert here.
But this is like, hey.
As a female, they're saying,
"I can engage in lyrical
sexuality as well.
"This is not something that
should be reserved for the men
"back in the 80s and 90s.
"This is something that
hey, this is my body.
"It's my desires, it's my world.
"Slurp up my spaghetti."
Oh right, man.
You know?
And it's just so out there.
I mean first of all,
what is radio anymore?
But like, this is just out there.
I mean I give a family account to,
and then like there's age
restrictions for Lando
but I mean Lincoln's 17,
Lily's off at college.
I mean Lando would implement
his own age restrictions.
They don't.
I don't think he actually
have, you don't have to do it.
But you know it's,
it's, where's this gonna go from here?
I don't know but it seems like it's,
we've fully arrived at I'm
putting my sexuality out there
and I'm speaking about
it in explicit terms.
And it's mainstream.
The way we talked about N. W. A.,
there was a lot of misogyny.
Lots and lots of problems with that.
Objectification, you know?
The list goes on and on.
But you know, for something that can be,
to some people could
be equally as offensive
because of the words and
concepts that are used.
But then it's like,
yeah when I heard about WAP I was like,
"Why is this being celebrated?
"This is like, I feel embarrassed."
You know?
This is very explicit.
And so, what I said is how
I began to understand it.
So you're saying that like.
There's such a progression.
If you go back to Garth Brooks
and this 46-year-old wheat farmer's wife.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What she was really saying
when she was saying, come ride the,
she wants to ride the
thunder she was like,
"Come slurp my spaghetti."
Is what.
Yeah.
And now, now this many.
Stir my cowboy chili.
This many years later, it's
just, you can just say it.
Just say it directly.
But in 1997, if you
listen to the group Next
sing "Too Close".
"Baby when we're grinding, that's right.
"I get so excited, mmh.
"Oh how I like it.
"I try but I can't fight it.
"Ooh you're dancing real close.
"Plus it's real, real slow.
"Now you know what you're doing don't you?
"You're making it hard for me."
I think I know what he means.
Then, and then the girl
starts singing and she's like,
"Step back, you're dancing kind of close.
"I feel like a little poke
coming through on you."
And this is pre-Facebook.
So.
Right, that was just
a weird song back in 1997.
It's like on the radio,
yeah talking about the,
just the dancing dynamic of,
I'm experiencing an erection.
Uh-huh, yep.
Something you don't have
worry about when you're
just sitting in your room
alone with Garth Brooks.
I mean that was just a weird song.
I mean you hear this song on
the radio and it's just like,
"This is just yeah.
"This does happen."
This is something to be aware of.
This is educational but this is a,
it's just a bit too blatant.
Like there's not, and you know, it's easy.
Well.
You want to criticize it,
well it's not that artistic.
But again,
I don't want to start applying
that to Megan Thee Stallion.
Well you mentioned WAP.
I'd like to meet her with
a clean conscience and say,
"I've never said
"anything negative about you."
I think you're prepared.
"I think you're
"a great person, let's be friends."
You mentioned WAP.
Someone else was talking
about wetness back in the day.
MC Hammer.
Oh you gonna go.
You gonna do this?
Yeah so I'm going back
to MC Hammer because
what MC Hammer represents
is how on the same album,
in fact almost back to back
but actually there was a song in between.
You're talking about the, when he blew up.
We're talking "U Can't Touch This" days.
That album?
Actually I don't think that these two,
I think these two might be on
"Please Hammer Don't Hurt 'Em".
Oh.
Which is the second album
and then the third that blew up was.
No no no, it's on "Please
Hammer Don't Hurt 'Em".
That's what I said.
Yeah that's the one with
"U Can't Touch This".
Oh I thought that "Please
Hammer Don't Hurt 'Em"
was oh okay.
So it was the first one.
No, it's the second album.
That's the one he really blew up.
So "U Can't Touch This"
was on "Please Hammer Don't Hurt 'Em"?
Okay.
Yep, that's what
I've been trying to say.
All right.
1990.
It's his third studio album.
Again as white kids in
Buies Creek, North Carolina
at the time.
"U Can't Touch This" was just
like, it was just something.
It just was like spoonfeeding us with.
Yeah, when you're 12 years
old it's amazing man.
So on this album there's two songs
that I'm gonna read the
lyrics to to kind of,
this was confusing for me at the time
because we had "Soft and Wet".
Yes.
And then we had
"Pray", we gotta pray.
Just to make it today.
Almost back to back.
I'm gonna, I'll run through
this pretty quickly.
Soft and wet.
Yeah.
"Soft and wet, that's how we like 'em.
"Soft and wet, yo baby come here.
"Yo baby, tell me what's your name?
"They call me Hammer and
I'm rows from the game.
"I see your face, it
stands out from the crowd.
"Move a little bit closer,
let me be your style.
"I'm crazy baby, I'm
crazy about your love.
"Let me tell you about myself.
"Now I'm a little bit
different than the average Joe.
"I like my girls and then
I like a little bit mo.
"Excuse me girl, I
don't mean no disrespect
"but tell me girl, are you soft and wet?"
Yeah.
"Crazy baby.
"I'm crazy about your love.
"I'm gonna tell you,
I know how I like 'em.
"I like 'em soft and wet.
"I like 'em soft and wet, check it out.
"You say you want me, well I want you too.
"You say you need me
girl, then I need you.
"You say you love me, well I love you too
"but there's a few
things that we got to do.
"I'm crazy baby, I'm
crazy about your love.
"How we like 'em homeboys?
"Soft and wet."
Yeah.
"I told you we like 'em
"soft and wet."
Soft and wet.
"Let me explain myself again.
"Soft and wet, how we
like 'em in the front?"
Soft and wet.
"My homeboys in the
back, how you like 'em?"
Oh, they're talking about
not the front and back
of the partner?
Talking the front and back
of the room.
Yeah I got you.
Got you with that.
All you need to say for this part
is soft and wet.
Soft and wet.
"Pump it up, pump it up, pump it up."
Soft is the.
I don't know this song
because I would always
fast forward on the tape.
It made you uncomfortable?
I would not listen
to this song.
It wasn't a good song.
As a 12-year-old, I would not do it.
"Soft is the feeling of
your baby smooth skin."
Great.
So we're not talking leathery hands here.
But is he about to describe the wet?
"Wet is the feeling that says,
"'Let the Hammer in.'"
Okay.
You know what the Hammer is.
"Soft and sexy."
It's his rap moniker.
It's his rap name.
"You got it that way, wet is what happens
"when we both start to play.
"Good she is, I should
know, hype the feeling
"when my ninja starts to grow."
So he just admitted to
it being normally hidden?
Well he's a grower, not a shower.
It's okay.
I think he's saying he's
uncircumcised, it's hooded.
Oh, wow Link.
That is some insight, you're right.
Yeah.
MC Hammer
is not circumcised.
I've never seen it.
But yeah, it seems that
he's uncircumcised.
And we met him from a distance at a party
but I couldn't tell from that distance.
He lost his phone.
He was also clothed.
He made an announcement from the DJ booth,
"If anybody finds Hammer's
phone bring it to me."
Yeah, I'm Hammer.
"I'm Hammer".
Okay.
Yeah and then "Pray" was right after that.
So it's like all right,
and then when you get, I don't know.
Hard and dry we can go to church.
Okay, so this is just called "Pray".
"Pray" was actually a
single which is weird.
"That's word we pray.
"Pray, pray."
Are you trying to cleanse
us by reading these lyrics?
I don't want to hear the "Pray" lyrics.
It did, it did come.
Well.
This song sucked.
"We got to pray just
"to make it today."
Make it today.
"I said we pray, pray, pray."
Pray.
"Oh yeah we pray."
"We got to pray just to make it today."
I listened to this one 'cause I felt like
it was Christian.
Yeah it's a pretty simple message here.
But I think that, the
thing I didn't understand
is that in my particular
worldview at the time,
these, the softness and the wetness
which I was obviously
very into the idea of.
That wasn't something
that God wanted for me yet
and I don't believe that Hammer
was talking about his wife.
You know what I'm saying?
Right.
So we can talk about softness and wetness
if you're talking about your wife.
Song of Solomon right?
Okay, yeah it's in the Bible.
But you probably shouldn't
make a song about it.
You know, keep it in the bedroom.
But I was just like,
"Man he's talking about
this thing but then he's
"praying."
I mean if you can put it
in the Bible, you can
make a song about it.
Right, but then he's praying
and he's not apologizing for it.
I didn't understand.
You know and now it's like,
I can understand it now.
You know?
I'm a spiritual being, I'm a sexual being.
And you know, I'm not gonna
speak into the culture
that Hammer came from.
Beyond the fact that like okay,
there's a church, there's a church element
and there's a sexual element.
I mean and it's not just,
so I'm not saying anything
really about Black culture
or growing up in Oakland
or wherever he was from.
I think it's true to, it's
a human truth you know?
We're sexual beings,
we're spiritual beings.
And also wetness is an
important part of the process.
I mean let's just be honest right?
I mean that's an indication
that we're all on the same page.
Yeah.
Obviously the main.
That's important.
The main indication
is verbal consent.
So I need to be clear about
that but I'm saying that.
Yeah and also being of an age of consent.
Right, as we established.
And which.
He was 18.
Garth was 18 when he made love
with that 46-year-old wheat farmer okay?
Well I need to take us to
another place that's a little.
Don't get any, don't get it twisted.
Well I'm gonna twist it.
Oh gosh.
Okay 'cause first of
all I want to talk about
"Knockin' da Boots" which is you know,
an H-Town song from the 90s.
"Give me some good love.
"Somebody rockin' knockin' da boots."
I can't not sing it.
Wow, that's a good one.
"A-give me some good love.
"Somebody rockin' knockin' da boots."
Now knocking the boots as it turns out
was an old Western slang.
Yeah because.
From the cowboy days.
The boots.
But in the 90s you got
all of these rappers wearing Timberlands.
They're wearing boots and then
they're talking about like.
Do you think it's from
you're wearing the boots
while making love?
Because I always pictured
it was you had the boots off
and they were next to the bed
and the bed is moving the floor
and so the boots are going
up and down on the floor.
That.
You think people
were wearing shoes making love?
Boots?
That's where.
I have the answer to that question.
Okay.
Back in the Western era
where it first came about.
Yeah it was like you're putting
your boots under the bed.
Whose bed have your boots been under?
Okay.
Shout out to Shaniah.
But I owned the Bell Biv DeVoe "Poison"
tape.
Poison.
1990 but another single after
that was called "Do Me".
Oh, they played that
at our freaking dance.
"Do Me" was played at our dance.
Again, 12 years old, 13 years old.
"Take a look at me, tell me,
do you like what you see?
"Do you think you can?
"Do you think you
"can do-oo-oo me?"
Do me.
"Kiss me pretty baby.
"Touch me all over.
"Girl, what makes you think you can do me?
"Do you think you can do me girl?
"Do me baby.
"Ho-o, do me baby.
"Do you think you can't?
"Do-oo-oo-oo me baby.
"Do me baby."
Second verse.
I got it, do me.
"Girl, let your hair down.
"Take off your clothes
and leave on your shoes."
Ah yes!
"Would you mind if I looked
at you for a moment?"
That is kind of sexy.
"Before I make sweet love."
Then, the other guy comes in.
I think this is a, I don't know
if it's Bell, Biv or DeVoe.
But I, oh yeah.
Yeah, I need to throw one
of them under the bus.
"Backstage, underage,
adolescent, how you doing?
"Fine, she replied.
"I sighed."
Whoa whoa, whoa whoa, whoa.
"I like to do the wild thing.
"Action took place, kind
of wet, don't forget.
"The J, the I, the M, the M, the Y.
"Why y'all?"
That's the Jimmy.
Jimmy, kind of him.
"I need a body bag."
So his only concern was wearing a condom.
Good gracious, what year was this?
1990, so yeah this is troubling right?
Slightly problematic.
"Backstage, underage,
"adolescent.
"How you doing?
"'Fine' she replied."
Action took place.
This is, this is not good.
This is a, I mean,
this is like the commission
of a crime in song.
Yeah but this is not the type of thing.
I don't know, this was on the radio.
Yeah, it just makes me feel
uncomfortable you know?
And it's?
Well, yeah I mean.
And it's not about.
This is not the
only song that spoke of such things.
But you, oh yeah that's true.
For many, many, many years.
This is probably the very end of,
I would say that by the end of the 90s,
no one's talking about
this in popular music.
Yeah but there was a lot of like.
I think the 90s was the ushering out
of this being something that like yeah,
we could talk about this
and try to make it seem like
it's okay by talking about it you know?
So.
It's just a weird,
bad, bad choice of a lyric.
But there was a lot of very
overt, let's sing about sex.
I mean you, but there was
some female empowerment
happening back then.
You got Salt-N-Pepa with "Shoop"
and then after that was,
"Let's Talk About Sex".
They were very empowered but they were in,
so definitely a precursor
to what we're seeing today.
Uh-huh.
And so
they were doing good work in my opinion.
But you got people like Color Me Badd
which had to add an extra D on the end.
It's like, well are you
compensating for something?
You're literally adding
another D at the end of bad.
And then they opened that pottery place.
After that.
Yeah, yeah that is the best technique.
1991, "Tik Tok, Ya Don't Stop"
to the "Tik Tok, Ya Don't Stop".
Yeah, "Girl you make me feel real good.
"We can do it til we both wake up."
It was like oh really?
In my experience that's not.
You know we can both do it in our sleep
Yeah, that's potentially
problematic as well
depending on your
interpretation of those events.
I think it just means let's
do it until the morning
and I think it just made a.
I do think it's possible though.
You can fall asleep in the act of coitus.
I think the act of coitus stops
the moment you fall asleep.
When you're done but you like,
you stay.
Yeah.
In position.
Yeah well.
I mean there's that, what's that all?
I'm a very large man.
My wife is pretty small.
Oh God.
I don't think this is a.
What are you talking about?
You talking about your entire body?
I weigh 210, 215 pounds.
Okay, yeah.
You're talking about your whole body.
I just want to clarify that.
I don't know.
You're the one
that brought this up.
The night where I fell
asleep inside you.
Oh, Merle Haggard talked
about that kind of.
No.
We talked about
falling asleep on the floor.
The night we made love in the hallway
and slept all night long on
the floor is the Merle song.
He didn't specify that
they were still conjoined.
But that's how I've
always pictured about it.
I'm talking about the
Third Eye Blind song.
Okay.
Anyway, to get back to this.
Where's my tab?
Yeah, "I want to sex you up.
"Oo, oo, oo, oo, oo.
"I want to sex you up, all night girl.
"You make me feel good.
"I want to sex you up."
Like this is just happening on the radio.
There was no you know?
It was the point where that
just started happening.
I remember the first time
I was riding in a car
with my mom and that
George Michael came on.
"I Want Your Sex" and my
mom was just singing it.
I've told this story
before Because it's just,
it really.
Whoa.
Scarred me.
Good gracious.
♪ I want your sex ♪
Hold on, it scarred you?
♪ I want you now ♪
But she's the one
who gave you the pamphlet.
It was pretty good though you know?
She worked at the
Health Department.
It was a good message.
It was like my mom's
just jamming in the car.
♪ I want your sex ♪
Hey mom, I'm also in the car.
Can you just wait until I'm not in the car
to sing this George Michael song?
But then by the early 90s it was like,
"Yeah how can we just
be blatant with do me.
"I want your sex.
"I want to sex you up."
But if you listen,
in fact recently when I was back home,
my parents were talking
about their favorite song
and boy I wish I could remember it.
But it was.
Rocking Robin.
It was like a 1950s song
and then they were like,
"Oh we listened to that song
"and we realized it's really dirty."
And I don't remember
what it was.
Yeah that's the fun though.
But basically it was about,
yeah it was about just getting into bed
and making love and it was
a little bit more coded
than the stuff is today.
But I think that's the thing.
Is that we have this perception,
I think this is one of the
points that you're making
as you talk about the WAP thing.
You know, especially from our background
of being sort of culturally conservative
for a really long time.
You had this tendency to think that,
the disposition is to think
that things are devolving
morally over time right?
That's how we used to think right?
Is that things are getting worse right?
The standards are getting lower.
Whereas when you have
a progressive mindset,
you think about it from
a different standpoint
which is people are getting more rights.
People are getting more acceptance.
People are you know,
able to express themselves
in ways that they used to
not be able to express themselves
due to oppression or whatever.
Yeah.
And I think that that's true.
But the point I,
I find interesting is that they've all,
everyone's always been
talking about these things.
Everyone's always been singing about them.
Everyone's always been writing about them
and just because the
curtains are pulled back
a little bit more and it's
a little bit more honest
and explicit.
And I'm saying the word
explicit literally means
very, very clear and unveiled
right?
Spelled out.
And how does that make it
worse I think is the question.
Yeah you were singing about
the same thing 50 years ago.
You're still singing about it.
You know, there's some
things that are problematic.
Like being able to spot the
actually problematic thing
like you spotted
in that Bell Biv DeVoe song.
Right.
It's like oh, now we're
talking about somebody
being taken advantage of.
Now we're talking about a power imbalance.
Now we're talking about somebody's will
and rights being violated
in an underage situation.
That's the piece of that
that we need to be able to recognize.
It isn't the fact that
someone's saying do me
is the bad thing.
Huh, right.
People have been saying do me
since the dawn of time and by the way,
that's how we all got here
'cause somebody did somebody
you know what I'm saying?
So it.
They could've done it
in the morning.
They could've done it in the night.
They could've done it
when you want to do it.
Just do me.
Right.
And so even something that
to me seemed very incongruous
back in the day to hear Hammer
talk about soft and wetness,
softness and wetness and
then praying two songs later.
I think the point is is that
Hammer may have understood more
than we gave him credit for at the time.
Now I do not believe his music holds up
but I'm not looking back with
the same kind of judgment
that I had at the time.
"U Can't Touch This" was unbridled,
undeniable pop hit and it has to hold up.
I do not accept that.
That particular song.
Well mostly because it was a bass line
from another song that
was actually really good.
Yeah, yeah I mean if you're
gonna co-op Rick James,
"Super Freak".
Yeah, right.
Then you're off to a good start.
Yeah, so all you had to do
is just be like.
'Cause that, that holds up.
I'm gonna just keep playing this loop
and it's never gonna get old.
I feel like we learned a lot.
I mean there's been.
You know, I love playing
music in the house.
Like profanity is something that we,
we tried to not just
let run around blatantly
in our house as the kids were younger.
But Lando's finally gotten
to a point where he's like,
"All right, I've lost this battle.
"This is reality, people
say these things."
He doesn't, he's not happy with it.
Right.
But he doesn't like,
exit the room anymore.
And he'll ask nicely if I'm
playing something that is.
Too many curse words?
Too much.
But again, to me it's not
about the curse words.
It's about the content
of what he's saying.
Is he about to get an education at 12
that he's not ready for?
I'm not gonna play that.
No I'm not gonna play that in the house,
I'm not gonna play that in the car.
I'm not gonna play WAP
in the car with my kid.
Like somebody expressing themselves
with some colorful language,
I just think that's you know,
that's self expression, it's language.
But I think you should
start with "Soft and Wet".
You start with "Soft and Wet"
and then you move to "WAP".
If you want my advice.
I mean there's definitely,
there's definitely a profanity playlist
that I can create.
And throw "Pray" in there.
That would be funny, to create a,
by the end of this playlist
you're gonna be totally debauched.
That would just be a funny exercise.
I think he'll get there on his own.
Just through peers.
I'm the,
I'm like the.
You're the dad
who's trying to get your son to.
I'm the sex education DJ.
Imma take you down
on a musical journey.
That could be a moniker.
Well we were talking about
and you needing a helmet,
maybe you just wear a giant
condom over your face.
What if you?
Breathing is gonna be an issue.
No, no, it looks like you
can't breathe but that's the.
I don't want to be a.
If you were a DJ.
A personified condom.
But think about it.
This is just one idea.
All the schools
would invite you.
This is not.
All the public schools would invite you.
I'm not a clown.
You'd be a part
of the program.
I'm not a clown dude.
They're like the condom.
DJ Condom is, DJ Jimmy
is coming.
Jimmy Hat.
Jimmy Hat is coming to our school dance.
Who's that?
Jimmy.
Well I think it's that guy
from Good Mythical Morning
but he's also a DJ who wears
a condom over his head.
I don't know that.
Okay Imma put Jimmy Hat on the list.
Jimmy Hat.
But I'm not gonna be a.
Okay, okay.
I'm not gonna be
a mascot condom.
What if you just wear a hat?
Yeah I'm saying.
And if you look closely
you see that it's made of condom wrappers.
If you looked closely.
Oh he is wearing a Jimmy hat.
Just something to think about.
'Cause it's a sex education thing.
You're the safe sex guy and you're like,
fulfilling your mother's life work
at the Health Department.
That pamphlet that she gave
you back in the day about.
Yeah, everything.
Softness and wetness.
Is now coming to fruition
as you're teaching all the
children about safe sex
through cool music.
You know I do have my next gig.
Oh yeah, I know about it.
Are you expecting to be paid for that
because it's at my home?
No hold on, are you?
No.
You're bringing your top, your setup.
My top, yeah.
I'm wearing a top.
And are you gonna be tapping into
my sound system?
We gotta figure that out.
Yes.
I mean I don't know, I'm
not bringing a sound system.
That's on you.
So, well my sound system,
you can tap into it
through just like a,
either Apple or a Google.
You can cast to it.
Can DJ Jimmy Hat do that?
We need to do a test.
You need to test this.
Where are you setting up?
You need to start thinking about all this.
I'll consult but that's an extra fee.
If I gotta show up.
Just so you know.
We're doing a little
graduation party for Locke.
That includes, it's not
like all his friends,
that's a different thing.
Oh really?
Well no, no it is.
I thought I was DJing
for your son and his friends.
No no.
Which could sound sad
but I'm excited about it.
No no no, it is his friends.
But it's mostly like the families
that he kind of knows and
kind of grew up around
and also his very closest friends.
So it's not like,
"Hey I'm inviting
everybody from my school."
I don't know how, I mean actually.
I don't want to do that.
I'm not involved
in the planning.
That's not what I.
That's not what I want.
I thought this was just
like, all of his friends.
This is a real party that needs a real DJ.
Well you need to talk to my wife.
She's the party planner.
If there's gonna be a bunch of adults
and I'm sitting there like,
"Why is Link DJing over there?
"Why is he not at the party?"
That's gonna feel weird.
But, but can't you get it
going and then walk away?
Yes, I feel like but.
You said that you wanted to do
barbecues.
That's not DJing.
Yeah.
And I assumed
that you still wanted to
be a part of the action.
Well that's not DJing.
In a conversation.
That's not really, I mean.
I think you may be inventing
a new style of DJing which is like.
You don't know, you don't know
what you're talking about.
I am, I'm a member of the
party but I'm also the DJ.
Okay, all right.
I'm sure that this is a thing that exists.
I can do that but that's
not what I thought
I was signing up for.
You thought you were gonna have a booth
and you were gonna be
protected from everyone?
Yeah, I don't want to be
touching these teenagers.
I don't want them to
be getting in my space.
Oh we need to talk.
We need to talk more about this.
Okay.
I wanted to do a cool party with.
It's gonna be a cool party.
Kids.
Not a.
Some kids.
Not my friends.
There might be more kids than I realize.
Honestly I don't know.
All right,
we'll talk about it.
We'll talk about it later.
You have a rec?
It's my rec.
You know what I recommend?
I recommend us ending this episode
with some of the voicemails
that we've gotten that
allude to previous episodes.
This is a great idea.
Now.
So as we've talked about.
That's what I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna recommend
that you keep listening
as we shut this episode down.
But can I say that?
Yeah.
I don't necessarily
want this to necessarily
mean that we can't have a,
we can't also have a rec and voicemails.
True, true.
We reserve the right
to have recs and voicemails.
I have a rec.
It's continue listening.
Yeah.
To the closing voicemails
and if you want to leave one,
1-888-EARPOD1.
EARPOD1.
I listen, I love listening
to these messages.
Thank you for calling.
It's cool.
Some people are correcting us.
Some people are answering
questions that we asked.
Some people are giving
perspectives on things
and like these two you're gonna hear,
some people are just telling
us some funny tidbits
from their lives.
Hi, my name is Jacqui.
So I just have to share a funny
coincidence with you guys.
So this morning on my way to work,
I was listening to the episode,
the "Ear Biscuits" episode
where Link was sharing
Lewis' memoir and just
as he got to the part
where he was talking
about where his reflection
of Lewis living in D.C.
and running up and down
the Washington Monument,
I, on my morning commute
was driving past the Washington Monument
was which just such a cool coincidence.
And that then reminded
me, several years ago now,
there was an episode and I
can't remember the details of it
but I know that there was
someone called Mr. Noodle
and I was also driving
while listening to it
and a minivan pulled in front of me
and the license plate was
"Noodles" which again,
such a weird coincidence.
So you know, that's two times
that "Ear Biscuits" has lined up
with something that I am
experiencing currently
in my real world life which you know,
is only two times but
it's two whole times.
So anyway, cool.
Thought I'd share that with you.
Thanks for all the fun stories bye.
This is kind of random
but I was listening to,
I think it was your most
recent "Ear Biscuits"
about spending days for each other
and Rhett's rec was to
just go to the doctor
if something hurts.
And that's really funny because my wrist
has been bothering me all day
and I think it's from an
injury I had in high school
which was maybe like,
six or seven years ago at this point.
So, and I keep thinking
in the back of my head,
I should probably go to an orthopedist.
Orthopedist and get this checked out
but I just haven't done it.
So maybe I just needed Rhett
to tell me to go do this.
So thank you Rhett, you rock.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist
on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you'd prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.